hello you're watching mostly weekly and
I am unfortunately andrew heaton Puerto
Rico it's Spanish for rich port which is
sort of ironic because it's bankrupt
kind of like how Iceland isn't full of
ice and Greenland isn't very green and
lonely island has lots of fans Islands
are liars
but now Port Puerto is even less Rico a
month ago the vicious category 4
hurricane Maria ripped through the
island raising a 50 to 60 mile swath of
destruction but the worst part of this
tragedy and I think we can all agree on
this is that we didn't appreciate Donald
Trump enough
but luckily Puerto Ricans have been
spared the onslaught of Donald Trump's
category five man baby tweet storm why
because 90% of Puerto Rico is still
without power and 88% are without cell
reception and it's gonna be at least six
months before power is restored how is
this even possible to answer that
question we have to rewind the clock
five months ago to May 3rd or to White
House communication directors ago when
Puerto Rico filed for bankruptcy it
couldn't pay the 70 million dollars in
Oda creditors and that's because the
country has been an economic decline
since 2006 so to answer why Puerto Rico
looked like this and now looks like this
we have to ask why the islands been an
economic freefall since 2006 and the
answer is government that's my final
answer
Puerto Rico is without power for three
reasons we raise taxes which led to a
deficit which led to a brain drain which
led to a deficit the United States and
Puerto Rico had been flirting three
years since the spanish-american war
then the United States finally put a
ring on in 1952 in Puerto Rico became a
u.s. Commonwealth and they decided to
raise a couple of beautiful industries
together so the United States showered
Puerto Rico with corporate tax breaks
but then the honeymoon phase ended in
1996 the u.s. phased out those tax
breaks businesses fled the island and to
make up the difference the Puerto Rican
government started binge eating debt so
facing a whopping seventy billion dollar
debt to Wall Street creditors many
Puerto Ricans bailed for the mainland
the Puerto Rican economy has been so
wrecked that there are now more Puerto
Ricans living outside of Puerto Rico
than in bad news for Puerto Rico but
great news for the New York Puerto Rican
Pride Parade this results in a brain
drain and this labor exodus makes paying
back a deficit extremely hard it's like
trying to fill a hole but all you have
is more holes we made imported goods
more expensive in 1920 the u.s. passed
the Jones Act which requires all goods
shipped between US ports to be
transported by US vessels meaning that
Puerto Rico depends on the US ships
which make imports way more expensive
which is cool because it's not like
Puerto Rico imports 84 percent of its
food right huh because that'll be crazy
after the hurricane president Trump
suspended the Jones Act with the
breakneck reaction speed of six days but
hey he had more important kneeling
related matters to attend to
however residents are still suffering
from years of artificially high import
prices so even though forty three point
five percent of residents live below the
poverty line it's still crazy expensive
to live there don't believe me hey buddy
wanna buy some sugar only 40% more than
mainland prices Pepa puerto rico's
publicly run electrical grid adopted a
hipster approach to electricity
complete with dilapidated facilities and
vintage technology instead of using
modern energy sources Puerto Rico still
generates 2/3 of its power through
burning good old fashioned petroleum
which is very steampunk and retro and
dumb why because all that oil has to be
imported and requires a skilled
workforce so what happens when you have
to import expensive oil and handle it
with a workforce that's decreased by 1/3
over the past five years yes but there's
hope in a state of emergency the Puerto
Rican government can bypass permits and
immediately revoke regulations also
private citizens are turning to the
black market to put the lights back on
in an ongoing effort to become the
Batman Elon Musk is offered to save
Puerto Rico's electrical grid with
batteries and solar power making Puerto
Rico the lowest lane of electrical grids
but the more important thing is that
Puerto Rico is without power and it was
an avoidable catastrophe
we shouldn't have to reach a state of
emergency to discover the devastating
effects of taxation and excessive
regulation and because Puerto Rico's
without power people are going to die
from heatstroke the clean water supply
is restricted and the supply of food and
drugs is shrunk and worst of all we
didn't sufficiently appreciate Donald
Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]